o moço traz não vou mentir para você não
porque se eu não tivesse dinheiro hoje
eu tava na minha por causa de nada não é
porque situação de final de
relacionamento você fica borra com as
deu uma queda aqui havaiana me deu agora
um chinelo que eu não desejo que a sua
mãe saiba que existe é muito bom para
pisar para andar realmente é sensacional
agora nas costas só ai porque tudo na
vida o dinheiro tem uma decisão
sensacional porque nem tudo afinal dele
para si próprio aquela mesmo que você
pensou assim eu mesmo deu vontade de ter
uma casa só para dizer assim tira esses
pés em muitos da minha casa trabalha
hoje eu tenho mais de uma casa eu nunca
mandei ninguém sair de dentro da minha
casa que eu descobri que eu não consigo
velho mas a minha vontade inicial é de
um lugar alguém entendeu tá você me
esnobou na escola venha tomar do meu
belzinho você está vendo que estou de
roupa um pensar coisa de gente que tem
muita grana em gostar mas não dá meu
irmão esse é o problema eu acho que eu
não seria era famoso [ __ ]
a honra que não dá para fazer as coisas
normal do povo aí não dá fica tudo assim
uma dificuldade pronto quem foi que
passou meu número com andressa urach
está aqui perturbando meu deus aí [ __ ]
eu sou educadinho eu respondo ainda
bicho mas não vamos não é isso que eu
fico [ __ ] que a gente não tem controle
do próprio número de celular velho
certeza que ela leva essa pessoa
maravilhosa cheia das melhores boas
intenções mais boa que foi a pessoa
velho meu deus agora eu virei uma
estrela pop não pode fazer nada que o
povo bate foto do cara eu virei a manu
gavassi meu deus eu sou estrela pop mas
eu queria era só ser rico antes eu não
pensamento era esse aí consegui as
coisas fiquei famoso e em meu coração
não me deixa agir feito otária então não
consigo nem um cabaré que com 15 minutos
a rapariga tô levando ela para se
resolver as provas café com o pai dela
eu juninho mais curto sua filha rafaela
vem não vem falar com o senhor agora só
o seu que eu preciso pensou meu brother
você vai me xingar aí na internet eu tô
falando você vai me xingar vai me
detonar meu coração ele não me deixa ser
babaca brigada ele me faz de otária às
vezes por quê por exemplo de uma senhora
que tava lá em casa que ela fazia comida
lá em casa e quando ela ia deixar a
comida no andar de cima eu ficava com dó
eu ia buscar olha dizer não precisa não
deixa que eu pego eu eu fazer metade do
serviço meu coração imaginava as
perninhas da velha subindo para me
deixar alimento em cima sendo que as
minhas são as novas para descer não dá
para eu fazer as coisas que vocês diriam
vão fazer se eu pudesse ainda tô disse
ah se eu fosse tu isso eu pegava o jato
em cheio de mulher aí maldivas não dá
primeiro de tudo que não haviam nem bota
lá cai no oceano vai acabando a gasolina
não tem milha náutica gente tudo você
tem que ter um entendimento básico
e não fala besteira vocês acho que toda
avião é mesmo avião que vai para europa
o do menino do neymar do cristiano
ronaldo não é gente tem a ferrari dos
avião e tem o celta o meu é o celta o
meu fico preocupado com todo conforto e
fique preocupado que a alma da minha
criação que tá dentro de mim o piauiense
de 15 anos atrás ele se manifesta avião
bate com força no chão ampar eu digo
quebra filha da [ __ ] até o fim não sabe
quanto é que custa nada eu não tenho
filho não tem os cachorros mas o
enfermeiro então agora trabalhando para
ter sempre o maior por isso que você não
me vê perdendo tempo com ki-cocó pipi
popó porque passa aí do celta a ferrari
que é uma comparação tá escroto que eu
fico me sentindo aqui o cultivo sucesso
venha fazer parte do marketing digital
mas é só uma cooperativa metáfora
entendeu entre um carro que curtem um
alto que toma a bicicleta de rodinha e a
bicicleta
o mack alta que só pedala quem já
cresceu tá vendo eu cuido até parecer
otário mais eu sou um grande de uma
tarde aí eu só tô mal dos deixa não não
mexe com a tropa que o bonde é chapa
quente né [ __ ] nenhuma os
questionamentos levantados aí ao longo
do tempo sobre a minha beleza doença é
bonito ou é feio é isso né amiga que eu
mais me orgulho em mim canção a certeza
eu sou uma incógnita não é o brad pitt
cauã remo cauã reymond você olha nossa
cauã reymond verba bem o que é
rotarianos ou cauã reymond vai ficar com
babado na ponta da boca aí o pau né mas
o que ela está vindo você olha e fala
certeza que é lindo windows você tá
longe aí eu começo a lápis ou não não
não faz fica alguém são paulo ali na
faria lima esbarrou em mim e eu de
sentença velho você tá trabalhando
pessoal aqui velho nossa sem noção para
ir você e noção velho criticado e
humilhado pelos padrões da sociedade
agora me bota assim numa saindo do mar
ele vem saindo do
se você quer pensa coisas você olha
falar rapaz 6 12 entendeu sempre gerando
questionamentos sempre gerando porque né
você pensa porque mas eu tô cogitando
[ __ ] ele consegue fazer você nossa
velho por isso que minha cabeça não é
confuso e não me atrapalha que a gente
aprender alguma coisa com qualquer tipo
de situação é coisa de quem tem noção da
vida para você olhar para mim me
analisar rápido e falar assim o rapaz
esse menino morava hoje não tinha água
nem luz e hoje ele tem tipo um sei
quantos milhões é um negócio absurdo
esse menino que tem nossa na vida é
exatamente isso cara tem o nosso na vida
e não é agora que eu sou assim porque as
coisas estão fácil para mim não porque
eu sei que tão galera por isso que eu
falo e as vezes eu sinto como sim alguma
outra vida eu tivesse pedido muito para
ser rico e famoso parece que eu fiz esse
sabes muito queria isso demais demais
demais que esse rico e famoso e hoje eu
tô provando de tudo isso assim e cara tô
parando para prestar atenção e vem aqui
muito bom meu irmão é bom
e ai velho tem que ficar desviando de
gente estranha toda hora parece um
estranho sabe para falar comigo uma
ideia mirabolante um negócio que é o dia
dessa galera que ele levar para conhecer
o shake eu isso vai conhecer o cheque
onde é que é muito doidão um guepardo
levou nada meu amigo um pessoal é
estranho porque as coisas sabe gente que
compra gente mesmo sabe não tem só o
poder deu os contatos é o teu dinheiro
mas eu não sei com que que fala para
arranjar sei lá um vim sei com quem onde
é que vai no carrefour do extra eu não
sei não vão meu amigo será que esse cara
tem tem quarto com arma na parede tira a
ficar tirando o chão para gente dançar
feito otária de palhaça os amigos rindo
da cara da gente os outros lá colocou na
cabeça torta aba aba aba aba galera
essas coisas todas são comediante não
consigo passar uma situação da minha
vida que eu não consigo fazer uma piada
primeira menina que eu fui conversar
depois que eu fiquei solteira diz
qualquer dia tô na tua casa quer que eu
levo alguma coisa eu disse ele me traga
flores só quebrei o clima velho quebrei
o clima é piada em cima
e não tá descontraindo e ainda tem um
problema que as coisas fica tão fácil ao
ponto de tu parece assim mesmo podia
fugir tô te falando rapaz o cara fica
pensando assim toda hora que vai
acontecendo várias merda várias coisas
várias incomodações e pequenas coisinhas
que eu pense menor não preciso mais
passar por isso aqui fica muito
apetitoso à vontade de fugir se morar
com um monge chegar lá e o pessoal quem
é você e você apenas um andarilho em
busca de espiritas espiritual por favor
se alguns me deixa carregar água nesses
baldinhos eu amo uma manga laranja você
não sabe mas aí da trabalha aí vocês
fica procurando aí é uma loucura e
documentário netflix gente que diz que
viu eu no lugar que eu não tava entendeu
minha mãe vai no geraldo luís faz junto
na tela com aquele menino que não cresce
diz que quer até crescer e o geraldo
luís faz tempo de promete a injeção dele
da igreja aí eu esse menino não cresce
aí vem a fim de ter fuxiquei futriquei
contra o queijo
o ok tudo ok tudo essas páginas mesmo
cara indo embora não tem paz porque fica
alimentando assim uma nuvem de o meu
deus do céu por isso que bote meia às
vezes não têm vídeo do mês só que
ninguém no mundo que aguente né tanta
coisa mas eu tenho cabecinha boas e até
vim explicar para vocês as coisas de um
modo bem de idade para ajudar vocês
porque a minha vida graças a deus já tá
sensacional tenho muito mais do que eu
preciso para viver tô ajudando agora
mais pessoas por isso as vezes eu sumo
que eu tô trabalhando nos projetos que
envolvem mais pessoa e não porque isso
aqui envolve só eu no máximo mais uma
pessoa que é o meu editor
e inclusive quero aumento em que nós já
no som dos melhores tanto agora
envolvido e botar mais gente para
trabalhar estão buscando até no twitter
jovens pessoas que estão começando que é
difícil começar mas eu sei que um
trabalho junto comigo vai ter o
portfólio muito bacana pra poder mostrar
para qualquer empresa e trabalhar e
ganhar dinheiro para poder fazer o que
eu posso de fazer e eu amo eu sei que
você também ama que ia viajar eu quero
conhecer o mundo logo logo vocês vão
conhecer o brasil de uma forma
totalmente diferente no próximo à parada
do youtube que vai ser em lugares do
brasil que só eu conheço ninguém conhece
só eu que fui nesses lugares achei
sensacional queria que vocês vissem os
meus olhos agora vai ter muito mais a
minha cara eu quero que você me dê essa
oportunidade de lhe mostrar que eu vou
fazer um conteúdo sensacional é vai ser
top demais agora vem as informações
quantas vezes somos já estamos voltando
daqui no próximo mês seguindo as
orientações né da saúde ministério do
pessoal lá que reúne lá e fala assim
isso aqui podes aqui pode pode pode pode
pode pode quem diz aos caras eram falou
fica distante
e vai ficar do jeito de fogo passa tá
mandando show do netflix eu ia gravar em
julho em manaus o meu novo joão netflix
não deu tempo gravar por que aconteceu
toda essa maracutaia aí esse vidro do
carai micro filha da [ __ ] esse negócio
aí que se eu falar aqui de volta a
monetização do vídeo como todos os meus
vídeos ah meu deus esse vídeo eu fiz
porque eu tava com vergonha de ter
completado 40 milhões de inscritos aqui
e não tem vídeo aqui para peço desculpa
aí por não fazer vídeo mas é que a minha
vida tá tão boa que aí você disse
interessa mas agora se tivesse passando
fome lá nas kitnet no piauí estava
gravando três por dia brigando aí com
rezende para ver quem faz mais mas tudo
bem então eu também estou concorrendo a
vários prêmios aí porque todo ano a
gente concorre a vários prêmios não
vamos buscar nenhum vamos mas esse ano a
gente vai buscar sim se tiver prêmio
gente vai buscar então vamos fazer não
tiram aí ou não se você não quiser
também mas se quiser voltar em mim entra
nesse site que está no link da descrição
vai lá passando lá quando aparecer a
minha cara é a hora de voltar e clean
oi meu nome vou ficar dentro como é que
é que você sabe que vai votação é chata
mesmo por isso que eu não fico pedi
ninguém para votar em mim quer que eu
seja sincero acho muito chato ficar no
site tava procurando pensei que para
pulando ganhar prêmio trofeuzinho para
dentro de casa e eu acho chato mas
quando tem gente que eu gosto eu volto
eu vou por exemplo quer virar quer vir
aqui eu vou só falando o cara gosta do
carro de rock serrote volto também de
rock melhor pessoa do mundo clicando de
rock que eu acho que ele é a melhor
pessoa do mundo eu achei aí ah mas tem
também a gisele bit que fala oito
línguas mas nunca falou comigo nunca me
deu um oi muito perguntando não então
desculpa é as personagens vão tomando de
conta eu não tenho para quem fazer show
gente eu preciso de plateia você tem que
eu tô ficando doido brincadeira link na
descrição do vídeo você pode votar em
mim se você quiser diga para sua vida
agora eu vou fazer isso todo o vídeo vou
dar uma dica para você melhorar sua vida
sabe por quê porque eu vejo tanta gente
perdida eu não quero virar cores mas
também não quero fazer sabe fazer um
vídeo só para ver como eu cansar
felicidade não da atriz
esse é um espaço entre duas felicidades
já dizia frases tampinha chave passam a
dica para você se organizar escolhe o
que você quer e faço necessário para ter
aquilo que você escolheu não dá para
juntar 10.000 reais para comprar o carro
pequenininho você tá pensando que não
gasta tanto ninguém junto todo mundo tem
essa cidade todo dia junto meu pau
estúdio micro-ondas da mãe vai deixar a
mãe comer com a comida gelada não você
vai lá e compra o microondas para mãe
desinterei o dinheiro de novo agora eu
já tenho dormiu quebrei minha perna vai
ficar com a perna amolecida vai arrastar
não você remédio então você não consegue
agora quando você fala assim o carro que
eu quero é de 10 mil o que eu preciso
fazer para poder ter esses 10 mil aí
você tem um leque de opções inscrito do
quadro de opções para fazer várias
coisas boas que você consegue fazer isso
eu sei que seu salário é pouco não é
fácil mas eu também sei que você é muito
inteligente eu sei que você tem cabeça
sei que você tem
se você consegue conversar com as
pessoas e eu sei que se você acha que
você não consegue se comunicar direito
que você não sabe não tem um bom papo se
não consegue apresentar aquilo de uma
boa forma a pessoa para pessoa para
falar assim ó tá eu vou lhe ajudar você
vai fazer isso e a gente vai fazer isso
eu sei que se você não tivesse
habilidade você vai procurar ajuda que
você vai conseguir se comunicar direito
que a comunicação mesmo é a base de tudo
eu sei disso porque muita gente fala
comigo muito todos os dias muita gente
fala comigo eu olho mensagem por
mensagem tem gente que tá perdido no que
diz e tem gente que tá certíssimo e eu
falo para essas pessoas você dessa forma
aí você vai chegar longe demais falando
assim eu digo olha dessa forma aí você
não vai conseguir muita coisa porque
talvez não tem uma pessoa um paciência e
nem eu tô tendo agora para te explicar
esse entendeu então eu sei que você vai
fazer isso não é porque as coisas deram
certo para mim que tudo isso acabou é
uma vida excepcional que você souber
mesmo usar para as coisas certas meu
irmão é excepcional mas não exclui eu
ter gasto igual a todo mundo
a proporção muito maior que faz até você
ficar louco sabe mas eu tenho uma cabeça
boa para ajeitar minha cabeça e para dar
um na sua se você quiser é só você
comprar o meu curso de marketing digital
tô brincando de brincadeira para quebrar
o gelo outra coisa muito importante eu
tô gravando duas séries originais para
esse canal aqui e graça mesmo é para
vocês pegando do meu e estou fazendo e é
para vocês é um presente também eu
espero que vocês gostem me apoie porque
eu tô fazendo independente mesmo do
fundo do meu coração para que vocês
gostam coisas escritas por mim e pelos
meus amigos né pelo robson pelo bruno
pelo xavier eu não posso deixou só
amigos meus me acompanharam desde o
piauí lá desde quando a gente começou
desde o início brian também tá envolvido
já tenho todo mundo tá participando é
uma forma que eu tenho de falar para os
meus amigos assim olha cara eu fui te
embora e deixar todos vocês aí mais
vamos todos brilhar era todo mundo com
seus carros todo mundo do suas casas
todo mundo faz o que quiser depois
quiser e preso aí com vocês e eu vou
o motivo disso eu queria que você me
desse essa oportunidade de mostrar para
vocês mesmo os meus meninos tão ajudando
muito eles eles estão me ajudando muito
também porque eu sou aprendi junto com
ele tá bem que você puder de lá e quando
sair espere gera engajamento quando eu
postar vai lá e comenta marca seus
amigos lá para dizer olha e vai sair
essa série do mais vai dar certo eu tô
botando muita fé nisso